there's lots of problems that plague our
regular culture
there's this world where it's free of a
lot of those problems
what's happening to you
ah bollocks
i'm just gonna visit the men's room real
quick you're welcome to do that on me oh
uh
well it's uh
and this totally reminds me of a german
porno i downloaded
ah this is drug induced street creator
give it a shot
well great story yeah we should get
together again very soon we're not done
yes
down karen i'm not done with the story i
consider myself a romance you know how
when you meet someone and they just
already are the person they're meant to
be
that was adam and molly is the kind of
cute klutzy girl that sometimes will
drive you a little bit crazy but you
can't help
the first time you encountered
the signal
okay okay okay so we have our main
character not quite
there was another character that was
just as important two of us
new york city my sons i have trained you
your whole lives
to protect the city above
this isn't perfect anymore
drink
excuse me that was my moment you're
welcome
oh
let's go now